the jaws on these lumber forks can grip
50 tree trunks at a time this is one of
ireland's biggest exports at the moment
wood from state-owned forests
the Murrays have been in the timber
business for almost a century now but
Patrick and his son John worry about the
future their concern foreign investors
could buy up the timber and ship it
unfinished by passing the sawmills as
they see it government plans to sell off
woodland to reduce debts is the wrong
way to go ireland is very few natural
resources one of those is this land and
what it grows on its land the affirming
be dairy or via forestry and I think it
is a backward step to to relinquish that
to the troika the Murrays aren't the
only ones worried Ireland's forests
don't just provide timber they're used
recreationally as well here in the
Dublin mountains responsibility for
maintaining the public footpaths lies
with quilter the Irish forestry
commission we've got an appointment with
Carl Boyle head of mountaineering
Ireland he's outraged at the
privatisation plans I do not believe
that a private pension fund for example
or whoever comes in to try and take over
this the and purchase these crafts is
going to be willing to invest in
recreation like wilcher has an
Inquisitor will continue to you know
it's hugely important that we maintain
this immunity this public good for the
people of Ireland and those that come to
visit here as well wherever
environmentalists gather in Ireland at
the moment like this conference in
Dublin the proposed sale is top of the
agenda but economists like Alan Matthews
view the issue quite unromantic Lee he
says Ireland's huge debts make unpopular
decisions necessary timber was planted
as a commercial crop in this country
we're going to we're going to cut down
the timber when it is mature anyway so
the question is it does it make sense
for the state had to bring forward the
sale of those they did the revenue from
the sale of those that asset the timber
when we need it rather than wait for the
20 30 40 years before
that timber is is matures the trade
union impact says that's just naive
they've commissioned their own study and
its conclusion is devastating if the
state forestry harvesting rights are
gone the gun for 80 years and we will
have had a return of three weeks worth
of interest repayment I fail to see how
we can begin economic recovery if among
the assets we've lost is a profitable
state company that returns substantial
tax revenue to the Exchequer every year
and where we would see the profit
generated by that asset actually leaving
the country economically dubious and
politically controversial many Irish ask
why they should sawed off the branch
they're sitting on
is it the pressure of troika of of avi
EU of indeed maybe even the German
Chancellor and and this is a question
that has to be asked the Irish people
are entitled to their amenities to their
public goods and it's unfair it's wrong
if there are others outside this state
making decisions which is going to have
a negative impact on the people of
Ireland Patrick Murray agrees with that
sentiment the forests are more to him
than sources of raw materials for his
sawmills his grandfather felled timber
here for the state he felt that in 1923
unit was replanted and my father felt it
in the 900 a 1960s and was replanted and
I felt offended in 1990s and was
replanted and has now growing again so
hopefully my son's and fellow the next
time the Irish taxpayer is still
profiting from this timber there's no
green light for the sale yet still one
thing is clear the timber from the green
hills of Ireland is more than a raw
material